I think about ratatouille every time I
cook
even if I'm just adding salt to pasta
water that movie captures how cooking
feels or at least how I want it to feel
and also how I want it to taste
there are some movies and TV shows that
stick with you long after you finish
them and you just can't help but obsess
no matter how pretentious you usually
try to be the movies and TV I cherish
the most are almost always the ones that
stick with me in some unusual way
this past summer my roommates and I
realized we had a rodent infestation in
our house and during the ensuing chaos
of putting up traps clogging holes with
steel wool and always feeling slightly
uncomfortable on our ground floor a
particulars show from 2019 always came
to mind and that's when I realized I now
think about Chernobyl every time a
disaster happens in my life no matter
how small that show captured a feeling I
hadn't seen anywhere else but one that I
experienced all the time
Chernobyl portrays crisis how it
actually happens in real life American
disaster movies are full of heroes
individuals exercising the free will to
do what they think is right it's a
fantasy that goes all the way back to
spaghetti westerns the story that the
individual can write every wrong by
challenging their foe to a showdown or
by blowing up the enemy spaceship but
Chernobyl is anti story the disaster
itself has no spectacle it literally
happens in the background there's no
honor in what the Soviets had to do it's
scary it's disturbing it's anti heroic
in Chernobyl the potential volunteers
quickly realize they're being asked to
participate in a suicide mission but the
nervous recruits don't get a riveting
speech from a president standing in
between fighter jets shot at a low angle
that ends in everybody cheering and
celebrating they get this they'll do it
because it must be done there's no
rallying cry just like a real-life
disaster no one is there to make them a
hero and their sacrifice doesn't receive
any spectacle or sense of triumph in
fact their dangerous task is in part
shot in complete darkness
Chernobyl gave me something I didn't
know I needed I hadn't realized how much
I would enjoy a show that gave me such a
strong and realistic alternative to the
traditional and fantastical American
approach to disasters
very telling I can't help but feel like
I missed out on something special by not
seeing 2001 a Space Odyssey when it came
out in theaters it's not my favorite
movie of all time but I'll always
appreciate how bold and different it is
especially for a 1968 release sometimes
I feel like the golden era of filmmaking
has already happened like I missed a
party that I would have really enjoyed
when you grew up with a cynical dad
showing you films from a bygone era it's
hard not to think that way
well I ever get to sit in a theater and
experience something like one of
Kubrick's classics but then this fall I
saw a film that's probably as close as
I'm gonna get the lighthouse is a
complete trip into madness following in
the footsteps of atmospheric thrillers
like The Shining it feels unsettling and
hypnotic and the dialogue by writer
director Robert Eggers elevates the film
beyond reality and into the mythic John
pehle death with trembled read make the
ocean caves our bed it feels us epic as
2001 and as oddly mystical as The
Shining but this time there's a
postmodern absurdity to it that makes it
uniquely suited to the time we live in
it's a genuinely hilarious film but
anytime something funny happens you can
barely tell if you're laughing because
it's actually funny or because it's so
tense which in turn leads to more
tension in one scene Winslow played by
Robert Pattinson simply tells wake
played by Willem Dafoe he doesn't like
his cooking and wake responds with huh
Trajan ha the severity of his threat in
proportion to Winslow's drunken
admission is so absurd that it's
instantly funny but it also serves a
purpose it shows us wakes dangerous
sensitivity and his propensity to
manipulate others into saying and doing
what he wants the scene sets the film in
this unsettling no-man's land between
threat and hilarity that feels both
old-timey and modern
Kubrick's films were funny and had
moments of absurdity but if they were as
absurd as the lighthouse I think
audiences and critics from the 60s and
70s wouldn't have understood it to put
it this way The Shining never would have
worked in 1980 if it had fart jokes
the lighthouse builds on what made these
films innovative for their time but
elevates new ideas that work
particularly well for 2019 honestly a
lot of this movie feels like a meme it's
dark it's silly it's absurd and it is
entirely unashamedly and unequivocally
weird this film about two stranded drunk
farting lighthouse keepers shot on
lenses from the turn-of-the-century and
presented in a one by nineteen by one
black-and-white format sticks out like a
sore thumb in the era of the cinematic
universe but I think it proves that
there will always be room for weird God
[Music]
my go-to romantic comedy was always 500
days of summer
I actually saw a lot of myself in Tom
Hanson he's romantic to a fault and his
misguided expectations teach him how to
better handle future relationships
overall the film portrays his missteps
in a pretty sympathetic light after all
he is a hopeless romantic is it so bad
that he just wants to be with the woman
he loves from his point of view his
actions seemed justified but I've always
felt that we missed a part of the story
we only see the relationship through Tom
how do you think this story would be
told from summers point of view I think
it would look a little more like this I
can't stop thinking about flee back
because to my horror I saw a piece of
myself in her boyfriend's and from her
point of view their romanticism is not
justified or sympathetic it's actually
pretty lame and hilarious before
watching the show I hadn't seen with my
own eyes the struggle women have
navigating male egos in their dads their
co-workers or their partners older men
were never allowed to express how they
feel so they're doomed to a life of poor
emotional communication so I just want
to say very much for the younger
generation of men that finally feel
comfortable expressing themselves
they're still extremely clumsy and
fragile the priest in season two is a
perfect counterpoint to this fragile
male character in season 1 by becoming a
priest he has in a way escaped to the
sexual and paternal struggles men
usually face maybe that's partially why
he's so appealing to flee back I can't
stop thinking about this show because I
was shocked to see myself in pathetic
male characters and I realized I owed my
girlfriend a few apologies
it's difficult to define what these
works of art have in common but I do
think they all had a major directorial
vision each creator shared a story they
personally understood and this subject
matter expertise made their work great
the beauty of the Internet is that we
have instant access to experts in their
field if we want to learn something if
you want to learn the best ways to shoot
a short documentary for example you can
watch a class on that exact topic by
Academy Award nominated director Elaine
Sheldon on Skillshare
skill shares huge catalog of classes on
film web development and marketing means
that you can learn from the experts
themselves which is my go-to strategy
for tackling a new topic
right now you can get two months of
Skillshare for free with our link click
the link in the description to help
support this channel and to get two
months of unlimited access to thousands
of classes for free or you can buy
Skillshare annually for less than $10 a
month and as always thanks to our
patrons who make this channel possible
thanks for watching